Fox News Alert I'm Juan Williams and
this is the five we begin tonight with
our continuing coverage of the utter
devastation in Texas following hurricane
Harvey the most extreme rain event in
the history of the continental USA
moments ago President Trump returned to
Washington after a day of visiting first
responders in Texas in Houston were
still seeing dramatic rescue after
dramatic rescue such as this one
captured by a traffic camera on the San
Jacinto bridge tonight the mayor of
Houston instituted a curfew from
midnight to 5:00 a.m. in order to
prevent looting of evacuated homes the
death toll from the storm now stands at
16 including Sergeant Steve Paris a
highly respected 34 year veteran of the
Houston Police Force we can find him and
once our dodge team got there it was too
treacherous to go under and look for him
so I made a decision to leave officers
there waiting into the morning because
as much as we wanted to recover him last
night we could not put another more
officers at risk what we do in our
hearts was going to be a recovery
mission goodness the latest let's go to
trace Gallagher in Kingwood Texas trace
I got to tell you one we are about the
last rescue boat out tonight we are on
Lake Houston this is the Barrington
subdivision it's a Golf Club community
and we've been out here for about two
hours and we have not seen anybody but
the crew where West says earlier they
they saw a man who was on his balcony
and he said look I've got food I've got
water
I've got electricity and I'm not leaving
and it's odd because you can see some of
these homes actually do have electricity
though the water is rising inside but if
you are not going to leave now I mean
we're about the last boat out here it
means that you are going to ride it out
for the night you're betting that the
water's not going to get any higher
which it could be risky because it
appears the water really is not going
down at this point in time they rescued
some 400 people out of this area today
in Lake Houston this is the northeastern
part of the city
and we saw people today that really held
on as long as they possibly could
getting their valuables up to the the
upper stories before they left and they
came walking out or boated out with with
dogs and cats and suitcases and all
kinds of stuff just to give you an idea
of how fast this water came rushing in
we saw a couple of u-hauls
down about a block over there and and
the funny thing is it appears they came
here tried to load up all their stuff
and then we're trying to get out but the
problem is one guy told our crew that he
came up what we just hit a stop sign or
something we just actually rolled over a
stop sign he told our crew wand that
then he thought he was going to come
home and 15 minutes it or he walked
outside and it was entirely flooded the
entire neighborhood was flooded this is
kind of the devastation that we've been
seeing now for days there is a little
bit of good news because as you can see
it's not raining for the first time in
five days we even saw a peak of the Sun
a bit earlier but Wow
they've got a long way to go here Lake
Houston and the rest of southeastern
Texas one trace it's been a long day for
you thanks stay safe let's now go to
Caroline Shively who's at the Houston
Convention Center Caroline hi there 110
thousand people have walked through
these doors it's simply too much max
capacity was supposed to be 5,000 so a
couple blocks away they've now opened
the Toyota Center where the Houston
Rockets normally play they're going to
try and get some of the people who are
here without cots without enough room
and push them over there the city will
open a third mega shelter if they have
to but so far it's been holding steady
around the 10,000 mark we have seen
people of all ages walk through here
including two little girls we met
earlier today one in a tutu one in a
Cinderella dress we're also seeing the
elderly come in lying on the floor
because they ran out of cops here but
they are getting clothes they are
getting hot meals and this is where it
all happens this is where the volunteers
gather the clothes the shoes the things
they need and it is all being made
happen
by local Houstonians giving their time
some of their houses are even flooded
out but they're here this is amber
Townsend amber tell us what you're up to
and why are you here I am here to come
definitely give my time to the community
I plan speeds my passion but I had such
a burden I had to get out here today I
couldn't wait any longer I filled out
the form yesterday with the Red Cross
and I was like I've got to go serve and
so it's so cool I came here by myself I
didn't know what I was getting into I
just said just use me and so yeah how's
it work so somebody says what I need
shoes I have no clothes so it's kind of
cold you're actually sitting in the
drop-off section they actually drop the
clothes off here we literally were out
in the rain we're going and collecting
them and bringing them in we are
physically sweating through the sizes
right small medium large 3432 whatever
and then someone will come and they're
like oh my goodness we need somebody
that needs such and such we need baby
blankets we need socks and a lot of
people someone just brought in is like
ridiculous these are brand new I swear
most of these are is a dry cleaner they
have tags
I'm just so ecstatic because it's like
beautiful things it's not there you know
whatever they were thrown away it's
their best that they're giving to the
community amber thank you so much you
are giving your best to the community
here an outpouring of volunteers and
health care tonight one it's beautiful
to see Caroline thank you so much that's
sort of a break in the clouds to see
people helping each other like that
Thank You Caroline Harvey is also having
a significant impact on the state of
Louisiana let's go now to Ric Leventhal
who's in Lake Charles Louisiana Ric and
mom we're outside the Lake Charles Civic
Center which is now a mass shelter for
evacuees not just from this region but
also from Texas and it's been the
staging area now for some of the
flatboats we've been talking about the
Cajun Navy these volunteers bringing out
their boats to to help out with rescues
they're not all from Louisiana the guys
who own this boat drove here from the
Atlanta Georgia area so they drove about
a thousand miles to bring this boat here
to help out and in fact they can't get
into Texas right now because a lot of
the roads are closed and they're turning
people away so they're staging here in
lake charles where there may well be a
need for rescues again tonight last
night we witnessed dozens of people
being pulled out of a neighborhood that
was heavily flooded because of the
rising waters and they're expecting more
heavy rain tonight
fact that the flooding was so bad that
the Purple Heart rec center where a lot
of the people were evacuated to also had
to be evacuated and those people were
brought here to the Lake Charles Civic
Center which is as I mentioned is now a
mass shelter and we spoke with the
Louisiana Governor John bel Edwards
earlier today who told us that that this
this state is now offering its
assistance to Texas because Texas was so
helpful during Hurricane Katrina and
other disasters over the years so let's
listen to the governor we've always been
really really good at taking care of our
own and now we're being good neighbors
to Texas as well and by the way they
were great neighbors to us 12 years ago
today the Hurricane Katrina hit
Louisiana and we could not have had a
better neighbor than Texas there really
is a spirit here of helping out and I
wanted to talk to some of the guys with
the boats about why they're doing what
they're doing one of those gentlemen is
his name is Todd love when here's what
he told me earlier tonight it was pretty
frustrating you know getting oh very
trying to help people and they turn
around say we can't get in so he is what
it is I guess would you have kept trying
you think you could have got in oh we
could have found a back road or
something you know there's always a way
yeah and what's your goal out here just
to help as many people think help the
storm is headed here for Calcasieu
Parish overnight tonight into tomorrow
they're talking about possibilities of
four to six inches of rain possibly more
there are warnings for possible
tornadoes and this area is on guard one
so they've seen a lot of flooding here
it's been raining here for seven eight
straight days now the ground is
saturated when they get these heavy
bands of downpours that have been coming
through here the streets often flood and
some of these neighborhoods flood so
they're standing by and ready to start
rescuing people if necessary Rick thanks
so much for being on the frontlines I
hope you stay safe buddy
sure kimber latest let me turn to you
and ask a little bit about how you
perceive the idea of so much
consistently four straight days of rain
it's like something biblical is going it
is I was going to say it's like the end
times I mean I half expect Noah's Ark
you know that's what it seems like
and you've just really never witnessed
or seen anything like this the president
touched on that and really trying to
bring it home to the rest of the
because we can watch these images but we
are not feeling the power and the
onslaught of that water coming down
that's so incredibly powerful and just
people losing everything every memory
every memento and picture and piece of
clothing or anything that they had they
worked so hard for you know at their
jobs to provide for their families can
you imagine that just the feeling of
loss and disappointment and mothers and
fathers just probably feeling like they
let you know their family down because
you can't help but just feel wracked
with guilt over all of it you know and
when I see the people just chipping in
and trying to help each other out it's
really heartwarming and I'm just so sad
and devastated and thoughts and prayers
go out to officer Perez and his family
and here's a man trying to serve after
30 plus years in the community and went
out there again and lost his life yeah
in fact the story is that is he said to
his life I've got a job too because the
wife was trying to get him to stay home
he went anyway so Jesse what struck me
watching Caroline Shively is very good
reporting and with interview with the
volunteer was what a contrast to the
Superdome member the Superdome in
Hurricane Katrina and so now they've got
double capacity it's about 5,000 at the
Convention Center Houston 10,000 people
in there but it looks like everything's
taken care of and volunteers are there
yeah they've definitely learned their
lesson from Katrina I love just
listening to these reports for Louisiana
Governor said you know Texas had our
back and now we're going to have their
back it's amazing the scene you see
these two kids playing in the tutu's
it's just a beautiful thing it's a lot
of humanity out there and Texas is
making America great again
I thought the president's trip today
gave a real shot of adrenaline to the
crowd it wasn't necessarily a visit
where it's I feel your pain I'm going to
give you a shoulder to cry on it was
more cheerleading let's get let's do
this let's do this together
rah-rah recovery oh yeah there's a
little marketing and PR behind it too I
understand that he said we're going to
set the gold standard for recoveries for
future years but at the same time these
natural disasters have a way of making
presidents step up to the plate and move
beyond politics remember what happened
with Sandy where President Obama came in
really what Romney off the map put the
bomber jacket on got out
marine one toward the beaches with Chris
Christie and people look to the
president in times like this and you
think about the last couple weeks how
divisive things have been and how angry
the country has been and this has been a
real unifying moment for Texas for the
country and I think an opportunity for
the President to heal some of those
wounds so Gillen let me just turn to you
real quickly and say that one of the
points of controversy day especially
coming from the blogs on the left was
mrs. Trump's stiletto heels going to the
helicopter as they were flying off I
guess to get on the plane to Texas what
do you think people love to criticize
what women wearing all the time I think
it's outrageous and I think it has no
place in the discussion about what's
happening in Texas today
you know the FEMA administrator said
yesterday this really moved me and his
morning press briefing that this storm
has it has it could not have he could
not have dreamed the storm up excuse me
I want to make sure I get that quote
right meaning it's been so brutal so
disastrous so horrible for people that
it really defies his worst nightmare
today it's harvested a continental
record rainfall for the US so it's you
know we're seeing the images on TV we're
seeing the photos online on social media
but it's really hard to grasp and even
begin to understand what the people who
live there are going through you can
sort of see it and visualize it but you
can't understand it unless you're there
and so it's just been a heartbreaking
time for all of us they think the one
good thing to come out of all this
horror is these stories about American
resilience that we see over and over and
again it kind of restores faith in
humanity at least for me you know
stories like Sergeant Steve Perez the
Houston police officer who died local
civilians from Texas and neighboring
states who are rushing in on boats on
canoes on rafts any they can anything
they can find going door to door to help
people and animals and save them those
kinds of stories I think are just
incredible incredible for the country at
the time Greg what do you see well I see
and I hear a lot of the same things
which is we're talking about all this
coming together stuff and it's a shame
because it's ignore
all year round you know the idea of
basic good citizens citizenry is
actually mocked in the media because the
storyline and in in parts of Middle
America in Texas we're not is one of
oppression division and bigotry you
think about all the nonsense causes that
take up conflict air space I call it
conflict air space where there's these
ridiculous fights over bathrooms over
pronouns microaggressions identity
politics gender politics these are the
things that consume people in the media
people in academia people in
entertainment Harvey comes and washes
all of that away and reveals what really
matters is or not these these bizarre
manufactured squabbles but things that
actually happen to people every day in
their lives even when they're in over
their heads literally they aren't in
over their heads they don't need
inspiration from me they don't need
inspiration from a leader they don't
need inspiration from religious leaders
they inspire themselves this is the
America that that the news ignores
because there is no conflict to build up
you can't gin up anything with this and
there's no anti-shah helping out because
they can't find anybody to punch right
you know that's a great that depression
is too snob yeah they'd like to do that
too